JOHN: I'M JOHN HEILEMANN.
MARK: AND I'M MARK HALPERIN.
"WITH ALL DUE RESPECT" TO THE
EFFORTS OF AMERICA'S
TIMEKEEPERS, IT SEEMS A LITTLE
EXCESSIVE.
>> THE COUNTDOWN CLOCK TELLING
ME WE ARE 23 HOURS AND 40
MINUTES AND 50 SECONDS.
>> IF WE HOW TO COUNT ON CLOCK,
I WOULD NOT NEED TO TELL YOU
THIS.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS AWAY FROM THE
START--
>> WE DO.
>> [LAUGHTER]
OH GOOD!
I WAS GETTING.
>> 21 HOURS AND COUNTING.
THAT IS THE CLOCK ON YOUR
SCREEN.
>> WITH THE VOTE CLOCK SHOWING
TWO MINUTES, 17 SECONDS.
>> WE ARE COUNTING TO TONIGHT'S
CNN LIBERTARIAN TOWNHALL.
>> OUR COUNTDOWN TO FOR THE
JULY.
>> OUR COUNTDOWN TO SHORT WEEK.
>> 20 MINUTES ON THE COUNTDOWN
CLOCK STARTING NOW.
>> THAT IS WHEN YOU GO 3, 2, 1.
>> ♪ IT IS THE FINAL COUNTDOWN ♪
♪
MARK: TONIGHT ON THIS VERY NEWSY
POSH AND SPICY THURSDAY SHOW, AN
REGRESSION DEADLOCK, AGUN
CONTROL STANDOFF, AND DONALD
TRUMP'S POLICY PLAN.
BUT FIRST, A BREAKFAST
REFERENDUM SCAM.
POLLS ARE NOW CLOSED IN THE
U.K., WHERE VOTERS WEIGHED ON
WHETHER TO CUT TIES WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
WE WANT TO KNOW THE RESULTS FOR
A FEW MORE HOURS, BUT THE
OUTCOME COULD HAVE DRAMATIC
RESULTS ON THE FUTURE OF EUROPE,
BUT ALSO HERE IN AMERICA AND IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
THE VOTE COMES ON THE SAME DAY
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS TAKING A
BREAK FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
AND GOING TO SCOTLAND, WHERE
HE'S TAKING ON A COUPLE OF HIS
GOLF COURSES.
THE PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE HAS
PUBLICLY SUPPORTED THE IDEA OF
THE U.K. LEAVING THE EU WITH
HILLARY CLINTON SIDING WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA.PRESIDENT OBAMA
IN APRIL WENT TO LONDON, STOOD
BEHIND THE BRITISH PRIME
MINSTER, AND GOT ON THE "REMA
IN" TRAIN.
JOINING US IS OUR BLOOMBERG
COLLEAGUE.
THE POLLS HAVE JUST CLOSED
THERE.
TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW.
>> VERY LITTLE AT THE MOMENT IN
TERMS OF TURNOUT AND RESULTS.
AS HE SAID, THE POLLS AND JUST
CLOSED IN THE U.K.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GET AN
OFFICIAL EXIT POLL IN THE WAY WE
DO WITH A GENERAL ELECTION.
WE MIGHT SEE SOME OF THE PRIVATE
POLLS COME OUT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF HOURS.
WE ARE KEEPING AN EYE OUT ON
THAT.
THE FIRST RESULTS WILL COME OUT
IN ABOUT 2 HOURS.
WE ARE SCHEDULED TO GET
GIBRALTAR AT MIDNIGHT BST.
THESE ARE OFTEN APPROXIMATE
TIMES, SO THEY MIGHT NOT BE THE
EXACT TIME.
THE BULK OF THE RESULTS WILL
COME AT 3:30 A.M.
THE RSULTS OF WHAT IS BEEN IN
DECISIVE VOTE INVERSE HISTORY,
TO REMAIN WHETHER IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION OR NOT.
A FLOOD OF ISSUES WITH  -- A LOT
OF ISSUES TALKING ABOUT HOW A
"LEAVE" VOTE COULD HAVE ON THE
ECONOMY.
FOCUSING ON IMMIGRATION AND
OTHER ISSUES LIKE SOVEREIGNTY.
BACK TO YOU.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOHN, WE HAVE NO IDEA THE
RESULTS.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT?
JOHN: THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
EUROPEAN ISSUE.
THERE IS, AS YOU SUGGESTED, AN
AMERICAN COMPONENTS TO IT.
WHAT IS DRIVEN THE LEAVE FORCES
IS A BIG PHENOMENON ACROSS
WESTERN PHOTOGRAPHERS --WESTERN
DEMOCRACIES, THE ANTI-IMMIGRANT
ISOLATIONIST NATIVIST IMPULSE.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT IN THE LEAVE
CAMPAIGN AND THE DONALD TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
IT SEEMS TO BE A BIG TEST OF
THAT MOVEMENT.
HOW STRONG IS THAT MOVEMENT?
THIS MOMENT IN OUR WESTERN
DEMOCRACY, HOW STRONG IS IT?
THIS IS THE BIGGEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT TEST.
IT MAY GIVE US SOME SENSE OF
WHETHER THIS GLOBAL PHENOMENON
IS ENDING OR FLOWING.
-- EBBING OR FLOWING.
MARK: I DON'T THINK IT WILL
AFFECT THE AMERICAN ELECTION,
BECAUSE THIS IS A SPECIFIC VOTE
ABOUT A SPECIFIC WIN.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL IMPACT THE
ECONOMY EITHER WAY.
I THINK THE MARKETS HAVE ALREADY
FIGURED OUT THEY ARE READY FOR
ANYTHING.
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES IN THIS
AMERICAN ELECTION, I CAN SEE
THIS HAVING AN EFFECT.
JOHN: WE HAVE NO IDEA.
THE FINANCIAL MARKETS HAVE BEEN
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE NOTION THAT
REMAIN WOULD WIN FOR A WHILE.
IF "LEAVE" WINS, IT WOULD BE
SURPRISING BECAUSE IT WOULD DEFY
THE BULLS.
MARK: THE MARKET WOULD JUST
ABSORB IT.
JOHN: I HOPE THAT IS TRUE.
I THINK THE U.S. COULD USE A
MARKET SHOCK.
IF "LEAVE" WINS, JUST THE
NARRATIVE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN THIS COUNTRY -- YOU CAN LOOK
AT THAT AND SAY MAN, THOSE
IMPULSES BUT TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
THAT HAD BEEN FUELING THE TRUMP
MOVEMENT WILL NOT CHANGE OUR
ELECTORAL OUTCOME, BUT YOU CAN
LOOK AND SAY THOSE FORCES ARE ON
THE MARCH.
JOHN: MARK: WE KNOW THEY ARE ON
THE MARCH BECAUSE BERNIE SANDERS
AND DONALD TRUMP DID VERY WELL.
JOHN: WE WILL TALK MORE ABOUT
THE BREXIT VOTE LATER.
HERE AT HOME, THE GUN CONTROL
DEBATE CONTINUED ON THE HILL.
A BILL BY SUZANNE COLLINS THAT
WOULD'VE PREVENTED THOSE ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST FROM BUYING
OUR FIREARMS DID NOT GET SUPPORT
FROM THE MAJORITY OF THE
CHAMBER.
THAT FOLLOWED A REMARKABLE 25
HOUR SIT-IN PROTEST BY HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ON THE FLOOR OF THE
CHAMBER, WHICH STARTED YESTERDAY
AND ENDED AROUND LUNCHTIME
TODAY.
THE FOR JUST, LED BY CONGRESSMAN
JOHN LEWIS, WHO HAS HISTORY
WITH SIT-INS, CREATED BAD OPT
ICS FOR SPEAKER RYAN.
AT HIS WEEKLY CAPITOL HILL PRESS
CONFERENCE, RYAN CALLED THE WHOL
E COMPETITION AN AND APPROPRIATE
PLOY BY HOUSE DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS.
SPEAKER RYAN: IF THIS IS NOT A
POLITICAL PLOY, WHY ARE THEY
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY OFF OF
THIS?
A POLITICAL TRAGEDY?
WEDNESDAY -- WHAT THEY CALLED
FOR FIELD IN A COMMITTEE IN THE
HOUSE.
I CALL THIS A STUNT BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THIS IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
IT ALREADY FAILED IN THE SENATE.
THEY MAY NOT LIKE THIS FACT, BUT
THIS BILL COULD NOT EVEN GET 50
VOTES IN THE U.S. SENATE, LET
ALONE 60.
I DON'T THINK THIS SHOULD BE A
PROUD MOMENT FOR DEMOCRACY OR
THOSE WHO STAGE THESE STUNTS.
JOHN: PAUL RYAN NOT LOOKING
PARTICULARLY CHEERFUL THERE.
THIS WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED THING
TO HAPPEN ON THE FLOOR OF THE
HOUSE.
GIVEN THE DISCUSSION ABOUT GUNS,
WHAT IS THE POLITICAL FALLOUT
FROM A RYAN AND THE GUN CONTROL
DEBATE?
MARK: INCREDIBLE PASSIONS AND
ENERGY.
I WOULD SAY, GUTSYNESS ON PART
OF THE HOUSTON PRESS, THOSE THAT
HAVE -- OF THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS.
PAUL RYAN HAS ON HIS SIDE THOSE
THAT DON'T THINK THIS IS GOOD
LEGISLATION, WHO CARE ABOUT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AND THE RULES
OF THE HOUSE.
THE NOTION THAT YES, THIS IS A
CAUSE THAT IS POPULAR IN THE
BOWLING -- POLLING, BUT WITHOUT
RULES AND THE HOUSE, YOU HAVE
CHAOS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STRONG
EMOTIONS ON BOTH SIDES.
IT SHOWS THAT THOSE THAT WOULD
LIKE ADDITIONAL GUN-CONTROL
MEASURES ARE AS AND HOWARD AND
IS ENERGIZED AS THEY HAVE EVER
BEEN.
THAT MEANS THERE MAY BE MORE
CHANGE IN THE SHORT TIME THAT I
THOUGHT JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
JOHN: THIS GUARANTEES THAT HOUSE
DEMOCRATS WILL BRING THIS BACK
IN A BIG WAY.
GUN-CONTROL IN RELATIVELY MODEST
FORM WILL BE THE CENTER OF A LOT
OF CAMPAIGNS.
THE PLACE THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
THE WHIP HAND POLITICALLY,
WHEREVER YOU STAND ON THIS ISSUE
-- THE NOTION OF DOING HER JOB,
TAKING VOTES ON THINGS.
THE SAME WAY THAT A LOT OF
AMERICANS FIND IT FRUSTRATING
THAT YOU CAN'T GET A SUPREME
COURT NOMINEE TO GET A HEARING.
WHY THE HOUSE CAN'T JUST
PROCEED.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE MEASURES,
VOTE NO.
THAT IS A POWERFUL TREATMENT
THAT COULD SWAY PEOPLE GOING
FORWARD.
MARK: RYAN POINTED OUT, THE GOOD
DISCHARGE IF THEY HAVE A
MAJORITY.
JOHN: THERE WAS INTERESTING
DISCUSSION LAST NIGHT, HOUSE
DEMOCRATS CLAIM THAT RYAN IS
JUST TRYING TO PROTECT A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
THAT KNOW WHERE THEIR
CONSTITUENCIES ARE.
MARK: I THINK THIS WON'T HAPPEN
WITHOUT THE PRESIDENT CALLING
PAUL RYAN DIRECTLY.
TO SPIN COURT SPLIT TH -- THE
SUPREME COURT SPLIT 4-4
CHALLENGING PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
IMMIGRATION PLAN.
IT BLOCK OBAMA'S EFFECTIVE
ORDERS THAT LINES TO SHIELD 11
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
FROM DEPORTATION.
SHORTLY AFTER, PRESIDENT OBAMA
HAD THIS TO SAY IN THE WHITE
HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM.
PRES. OBAMA: DURING ELECTION
YEARS, POLITICIANS TEND TO USE
IMMIGRATION TO SCARE PEOPLE WITH
WORDS LIKE AMNESTY IN HOPES THAT
IT WILL WHIP UP VOTES.
KEEP IN MIND THE MILLIONS OF US,
MYSELF INCLUDED, GO BACK
GENERATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY,
WITH ANCESTORS THAT PUT IN THE
PAINSTAKING EFFORT TO BECOME
CITIZENS.
MARK: BOTH THE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES WEIGHED IN.
HILLARY CLINTON PUT OUT A
STATEMENT, "THIS DECISION IS A
STARK REMINDER OF THE HARM
DONALD TRUMP WOULD DO TO OUR
FAMILIES, OUR AND COMMUNITIES,
AND OUR COUNTRY."
TRUMP HAS PLEDGED TO REPEAL
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS ON HIS FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE.
HE HAS CALLED MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS
RICHEST --  IMMIGRANTS RAPISTS
AND MURDERS.
DONALD TRUMP STATEMENT SAID
"THIS PHYSICIAN WILL DECIDE
WHETHER WE NOT WE HAVE A BORDER
AND SAFE COUNTRY. CLINTON HAS
HURT POOR AFRICAN-AMERICAN
HISPANIC WORKERS BY GIVING AWAY
THEIR JOBS TO IMMIGRANT LABOR
WHILE MAKING US ALL LESS SAFE."
HOW DOES THIS SUPREME COURT
DECISION AGAINST THE PRESIDENT
IMPACT THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE?
JOHN: IT IS A DECISION BY NOT
DECISION.
A 4-4 SPLIT.
IT POINTS OUT HOW IMPORTANT THE
LAST SEAT IS IN THE ELECTION.
IT GIVES BOTH CANDIDATES A
POWERFUL CARD TO PLAY.
THE FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY RESTS
ON WHO GETS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
NEXT.
I THINK THE POLITICS OF
IMMIGRATION, AND THE NATURE OF
THE COUNTRY, FAVORS DEMOCRATS.
I THINK HILLARY CLINTON IS
PLAYING A WINNING HAND IN TERMS
OF DRIVING HISPANIC TURNOUT.
MARK: THE ONLY ADVANTAGE I THINK
THIS GIVES TRUMP IS THAT IT
ENERGIZES HILLARY CLINTON IN
STATES THAT SHE COULD USE THE
HELP.
IT ALLOWS DONALD TRUMP TO TALK
ABOUT IMMIGRATION NOT IN TERMS
OF THE WALL.
THAT IS BECOME SUCH A HOT BUTTON
ISSUE.
IT ALLOWS HIM TO APPEAL ON
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND ON THE
BORDER.
THE EXTENT THAT IMMIGRATION IS A
WINNING ISSUE FOR REPUBLICANS,
THIS GIVES DONALD TRUMP A BETTER
CHANCE THAN JUST TALKING ABOUT
THE WALL.
JOHN: THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
INTENTIONAL TO NOT TALK ABOUT
THE WALL.
I AM WONDERING THE EXTENT TO
WHICH HE WILL GO BACK TO THE
WALL, OR THE EXTENT TO WHICH YOU
CAN ESCAPE IT.
MARK: I THINK YOU CAN ESCAPE IT.
JOHN: I WONDER IF THAT IS THE
CASE.
THIS WILL BE BETWEEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND HILLARY CLINTON ON THE
SAME SITE.
I CAN SEE HOW IT CAN PLAY TO
TRUMP'S BENEFIT, BUT IT PLAYS TO
THE DEMOCRATS IN A MUCH BIGGER
WAY.
MARK: WHEN WE COME BACK, HILLARY
CLINTON HAS A BIG ENDORSEMENT
DAY.
BUT FIRST, THESE WORDS FROM OUR
SPONSORS.
♪
JOHN: HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
ANNOUNCED 50 INVESTMENTS FROM
BUSINESS LEADERS.
SOME WERE BIG NAMES, WHO WORKED
IN THE WHITE HOUSE FOR RONALD
REAGAN AND GEORGE W. BUSH.
ON THE SHORT YESTERDAY WE
MENTIONED THAT CLINTON PICKED UP
THE THE ENDORSEMENT OF A FORMER
BUSH '41 ENDORSEMENT.
THE IDEA THAT SHE WOULD GET
ENDORSEMENTS FROM REPUBLICANS --
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THIS RACE,
ENDORSEMENTS FROM REPUBLICAN CEO
ARE MORE DAMAGING TO DONALD
TRUMP?
MARK: THE ONES THAT WILL MATTER
THE MOST ARE THOSE THAT COME
FROM THOSE FAMOUS NATIONALLY,
BUT ALSO STATES PEOPLE.
A LOT OF OHIO REPUBLICANS WITH
NO NATIONAL REPETITION.
ALL OF THESE MATTER.
ALL OF THESE ARE UNUSUAL.
THEY SPEAK TO THE ALIENATION
SOME SECTIONS OF THE PARTY HAVE
FROM TRUMP.
IT IS A WAY TO DRIVE NEW CYCLES,
AND THEIR MANY MORE COMING.
JOHN: I SAID YESTERDAY THAT THE
QUESTION ABOUT TRUMP'S BUSINESS
READINESS TO BECOME
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF IS A HUGE
PROBLEM FOR HIM.
BUT IT IS THE CASE THAT HE IS A
BUSINESSMAN WHO TOUTS HIS
BUSINESS SKILLS CONSTANTLY AS
CREDENTIALS FOR BEING PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IF HILLARY CLINTON BECOMES THE
CANDIDATE OF BIG BUSINESS,
FORTUNE 500 CEOS, IT BECOMES
CLEAR THAT SHE HAS THE SUPPORT
OF MOST OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY, THAT IS A HUGE ASSET
FOR H ER.
I CANNOT DISCERN WHICH IS A
BIGGER ASSET.
THAT IS A REALLY BIG DEAL FOR
HER.
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE THE CANDIDATE
OF BIG BUSINESS TEND TO BE
WINNING DEMOCRATS.
MARK: BILL CLINTON GOT
ENDORSEMENTS FROM BIG BUSINESS
FOLKS IN 1992.
IT AFFECTS FUNDRAISING.
A LOT OF THESE BUSINESS FOLKS
ARE THOSE WHO ARE BUTLERS.
JOHN: BARACK OBAMA DID THE SAME
THING.
HELPED HIM TOO.
MARK: HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL RYAN
HAS BEEN ROLLING OUT A LOT OF
POLICY PLANS OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS ON HEALTH CARE, POVERTY,
SEVERAL OTHER ISSUES.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL
PUBLISHED A COUPLE OF OFFENSE
ALONG THE SAME LINES.
-- OF OP-EDS ALONG THE SAME
LINES.
THEY SAY IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA
FOR TO JUMP TO SIMPLY EMBRACE --
FOR DONALD TRUMP TO SIMPLY
EMBRACE THESE PROPOSALS TO COVER
UP THE FACT THAT HE HAS NOT PUT
UP MUCH POLICY, IN ORDER TO
UNITE THE POLICY.
"THE HOUSE AGENDA IS THE TRUMP
ROSETTA STONE. AN OFF-THE-SHELF
TEMPLATE FOR GETTING THROUGH THE
NEXT FIVE MONTHS. A WAY FOR THE
PARTY'S NOMINEE TO SING FROM THE
SAME HYMNAL RATHER THAN STAB
EACH OTHER IN THE BACK."
KARL ROVE WROTE THIS ABOUT THE
HOUSE POLICY EFFORTS.
THEY VITAL TO THE GOP'S SUCCESS
AND MAY DETERMINE MR. TRUMP'S
POLITICAL FORTUNES. FISHING IS
HE IS MAKING THERE WERE CARTER."
-- THEIR WORK HARDER.
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT TRUMP WILL
EMBRACE THE RIGHT AGENDA, OR IS
THERE SOME DOWNSIDE?
-- RYAN AGENDA, OR IS THERE SOME
DOWNSIDE?
JOHN: IF HE IS SMART, HE WILL
EMBRACE MOST IF NOT ALL OF IT.
AND IMMIGRATION AND TRADE, HE
WON'T EMBRACE THE WHOLE THING.
TO MY KNOWLEDGE HE HAS NO REAL
POLICY SHOP.
HE HAS NOTHING FLESHED OUT IN
ANY WAY THAT WE CONSIDER A AS A
CANDIDATE TO HAVE.
HE NEEDS SOME TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
RYAN'S POLICIES ARE AT LEAST
CREDIBLE AND REAL.
IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT YOU SHOULD
OUTSOURCE THIS STUFF, BUT GIVEN
WHERE TRUMP IS, IT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE.
MARK: WITH THE PARTY PLATFORM, I
DON'T AGREE WITH EVERYTHING, BUT
WITH THE BROAD STROKES.
WITH ENTITLEMENT REFORM AND
SPENDING CUTS -- THE RYAN PLANS
ARE NOT BIG ENOUGH TO -- NOT
VAGUE ENOUGH TO CAUSE A PROBLEM.
JOHN: TO MAINTAIN THE RYAN
ENDORSEMENT, BY EMBRACING MUCH
OF HIS AGENDA, IT MIGHT HELP HIM
SOFT AND SOME OF RYAN'S TENDENCY
TO CRITICIZE THEM WHEN HE SAYS
CONTROVERSIAL THINGS.
MARK: A SAFE HARBOR.
JOHN: A, RICHMOND JOINS US TO
TALK ABOUT HIS ROLE IN THE 25
HOURS HOUSE SIT-IN RIGHT AFTER
THIS.
MARK: OUR NEXT GUEST JUST GOT
BACK FROM LEAVING THE FINAL 25
HOURS OF THE CHOREOGRAPHED
TEMPOR -- CHOREOGRAPHED
DEMOCRAT SIT-IN.
JOINING US IS CONGRESSMAN STEVE
ISRAEL.
STEVE: THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
I WORKED LATE SHIFT LAST NIGHT.
MARK: YOU LOOK PRETTY WELL
RESTED, ALTHOUGH I GET THE
VOICE.
SPEAKER RYAN WAS PRETTY DEFINED
TODAY.
AFTER ALL THAT EFFORT, TELL ME
WHAT YOUR BEST CASE SCENARIO IS
GOING FORWARD.
REP. ISRAEL: BEST CASE SCENARIO
IS THAT REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
HOME ON VACATION.
THEY WILL FACE ANGER IN THEIR
DISTRICTS.
THEIR CONSTITUENTS ARE GOING TO
WANT TO KNOW WHY THEY LEFT FOR
VACATION WITHOUT EVEN VOTING ON
SENSIBLE LEGISLATION LIKE
NO FLY, NO BUY.
THEY CHOSE NOT ONLY NOT TO VOTE,
BUT TO LEAVE WASHINGTON EARLY AS
THE DEMOTT EVEN WANT TO CONTINUE
THE WEEK'S WORK.
THEY WILL SPEND A WEEK IN THEIR
DISTRICTS FEELING SOME HEAT.
THEY WILL COME BACK ON JULY 5
AND FEEL MORE HEAT.
JOHN: TALK OF IT MORE ABOUT THAT
HEAT.
WHAT IS THAT HEAT GOING TO LOOK
LIKE FROM YOUR SIDE OF THE
AISLE?
REP. ISAREL; WE SAID WE WILL USE
ALL ALL OF THE TOOLS IN OUR
TOOLBOX.
SOME WILL BE SHORT AND SHOWN
WILL BE BLUNT.
TO TRY AND FORCE A VOTE ON NO
FLY NO BUY.
THE REPUBLICANS RETURNED TO
THEIR DISTRICTS AT THEIR OWN
PERIL.
YOU'LL SEE THE USE OF SIMILAR
TOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT
REPUBLICANS'  CONSTITUENTS KNOW
THAT THEY WOULD NOT EVEN ALLOW
US TO HAVE A VOTE ON THIS BILL.
NO MATTER HOW YOU HAVE FELT,
THAT WON'T EVEN ALLOW US TO HAVE
A FOOD.
THEY WILL COME BACK ON JULY 5
FOR A SECOND WEEK OF H EAT ON
THIS ISSUE.
MARK: CONGRESSMAN, DOES THAT
MEAN YOU ARE THINKING THAT
RESUMING A SIT-IN WHEN
REPUBLICANS COME BACK TO CAPITOL
HILL?
REP. ISRAEL: I WILL BE HONEST, I
DON'T REVEAL THE PLAYBOOK ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION.
BUT WE TOLD THE REPUBLICANS
EARLY ON THAT THEY SHOULD GIVE
US A VOTE, AND WE WOULD USE
EVERY TOOL WE HAD.
WE ARE WILLING TO DIP DO THAT
TOOLBOX AND DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
AS A MINORITY, WE HAVE VERY FEW
RIGHTS AND THE U.S. CONGRESS.
WHENEVER RIGHTS IS TO PUT
PRESSURE AND HEAT ON THE
MAJORITY.
THAT IS WHAT WE WILL DO NEXT
WEEK IN THEIR DISTRICTS.
WE WILL KEEP DOING IT UNTIL WE
GET THE VOTE THAT WE DESERVE.
MARK: YOU FEEL THAT YOU HAVE
PUBLIC OPINION ON YOUR SIDE, AND
THAT THERE IS A MOTION ABOUT
RECENT EVENTS.
WHAT IS THE THRESHOLD FOR NOT
GOING ON A MORE STANDARD ROUTE
AND DOING WHAT YOU ALL DID LAST
NIGHT, USING CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE
TO DISRUPT THE HOUSE FLOOR?
WHEN IS THAT APPROPRIATE,
COMPARED TO THE NORMAL TACTICS?
REP. ISRAEL WE TRIED TO
DISCHARGE PETITION:.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED 80 MEMBERS ON
THE DISCHARGE PETITION.
WE HAVE TRIED HEARINGS.
WE HAVE TRIED ALL OF THE USUAL
AND CUSTOMARY ROUTES TO GET A
VOTE.
ALL OF THOSE ROUTES HAVE BEEN
CLOSED OFF TO US, DESPITE THE
FACT THAT 80-90% OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WE TRY TO BIPARTISANSHIP AND HAS
NOT WORKED.
FOR REPUBLICANS PUT US IN THE
POSITION OF BREAKING TO
COURTROOM -- REPUBLICANS PUT US
IN THE POSITION OF BREAKING THE
COURTROOM.
THIS BILL IS A GREATER GOOD.
MARK: YOU BROKE DEOCRUM AND DID
SOMETHING THAT HAD NOT BEEN DONE
IN A LONG TIME.
TO DOES NOT OCCUR THAT HAVING
SET THIS PRESIDENT, THAT A DAY
WILL COME WHEN REPUBLICANS WILL
LOOK BACK TO THIS DAY AND SAY, I
REMEMBER WHEN DEMOCRATS DID THIS
WHEN I THOUGHT THEIR CAUSE WAS
RIGHTEOUS, AND WILL DO THAT TO
THEIR ENDS?
REP. ISRAEL: THAT IS THEIR RIGHT
IF THEY FEEL MISTREATED.
I RESPECT THAT AND SUPPORT IT.
WHEN DEMOCRATS WERE IN THE
MAJORITY, I CANNOT THINK OF A
ANY INSTANCEY WHERE WE REFUSED
TO HAVE ANY HEARING ON THIS
BILL.
PAUL RYAN WAS SO AFRAID OF THE
BILL HE LEFT WASHINGTON EARLY
LAST NIGHT.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
SESSION UNTIL TOMORROW.
ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT, HE SAID WE
ARE GETTING OUT OF TOWN.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT KIND OF
RESISTANCE, YOU HAVE TO USE
NONTRADITIONAL RECOURSE.
THAT IS THAT WE DID LAST NIGHT.
MARK: YOU DID GET A VOTE IN
COMMITTEE, RIGHT?
REP. ISRAEL: ON THE
KING-THOMPSON BILL, NO.
THEY WOULD NOT ALLOW THIS BILL
TO ADVANCE, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT IT HAS 111 COSPONSORS AND A
HUNDRED 80 ON THE DISCHARGE
POSITION.
MARK: IN THE END, WHAT IS YOUR
ATTITUDE TOWARD SPEAKER RYAN'S
ATTITUDE THAT HE PORTRAYED IN
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE?
REP. ISRAEL: I SYMPATHIZE WITH
HIM.
THIS IS WHAT JOHN BOEHNER WENT
THROUGH.
I THINK PAUL RYAN WANTS TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
I THINK HE AGREES WITH THE 75%
OF THE NRA MEMBERS THAT
SUPPORTED THIS BILL.
BUT HE IS A CAPTIVE OF A SMALL
NUMBER OF GROUPS IN HIS CAUCUS
THAT HE THINKS MAY TOPPLE HIM IF
HE DEMONSTRATES SOME
BIPARTISANSHIP.
JUST LIKE JOHN BOEHNER, PAUL
RYAN SHOWED THAT HE IS
INEFFECTIVE AND AS A RESULT, HAD
TO LITERALLY GET HIS CAUCUS TO
ESCAPE LATERAL -- ESCAPE CAPITOL
HILL.
MARK: THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
WHEN WE COME BACK, BREXIT FOR
DINNER.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THAT TASTE LIKE
AFTER THIS.
♪
.
>> TODAY IS THE DAY YOU CAN VOTE
ON BRITAIN'S FUTURE IN EUROPE.
I THINK BRITAIN WILL BE BETTER
AND STRONGER IF WE STAY IN
EUROPE.
TODAY IS THE DAY, SO GET OUT AND
VOTE.
JOHN: THAT WAS BRITISH PRIME
MINISTER DAVID CAMERON ON
SNAPCHAT.
HE WAS URGING THE BRITS TO GO
OUT AND VOTE AND REMAINED IN THE
EU.
THE POLLS ARE CLOSED.
AN ONLINE SURVEY WHICH ASKED
U.K. CITIZENS HOW THEY VOTED,
AGES 52% VOTED -- IT SHOWS 52%
VOTED REMAIN.
THIS IS JUST ONE POLL AND THESE
ARE NOT OFFICIAL RESULTS, SO YOU
SHOULD TAKE IT WITH A BIG PINCH
OF SALT.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE BREXIT
REFERENDUM AGAIN IS JOHN METALS
WEIGHT AND VONNIE QUINN, ANCHOR
OF BLOOMBERG MARKETS.
THE WORD OF THE DAY TODAY IS
ASYMMETRY.
HOW SO?
VONNIE: FOUR MARKETS, IT IS AN
ASYMMETRIC OUTCOME.
IF IT DOES HAPPEN TO BECOME A
LEAVE VOTE, WHICH COULD VERY
MUCH HAPPEN.
WE HAVE JUST SEEN THE POLLS
CLOSE.
IT WOULD BE A VERY ASYMMETRIC
DECISIONS FOR MARKETS.
WE'VE SEEN A STARTING RALLY THAT
WOULD PROBABLY ALL BE ERASED.
ASYMMETRIC IN THE SENSE THAT IF
YOU VOTE TO LEAVE, YOU ARE GONE
AND IF YOU VOTE TO STAY, YOU CAN
STILL LEAVE IN THE FUTURE.
GUEST: I THINK THE FALL IN THE
FALL IN STERLING WOULD BE MUCH
HIGHER.
MAYBE ANOTHER 10 OR $.20 ON TOP
OF THAT.
IT WOULD BE A HUGE THING AND
CURRENCY TRADERS ARE WAITING IN
MILD TERROR IN CASES HAPPENS.
PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING IN THEIR
OFFICES.
JOHN: DO YOU THINK THE FINANCIAL
MARKETS IMPLICATIONS WOULD BE
BAD IF THEY LEAVE?
GUEST: YES.
YOU WOULD EXPECT THE POUND TO GO
DOWN -- IT'S JUST UNDER 1.50 AT
THE MOMENT.
IF IT'S LEAVE WERE TO HAPPEN,
PEOPLE ARE SAYING 1.15.
THAT'S A SEISMIC CHANGE.
EVEN THAT IN TERMS WHERE
BILLIONS ARE BET ON A FEW DIMES
DIFFERENCE, THAT'S A HUGE DEAL.
VONNIE: NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF
SHORT-TERM SPECULATION AND
BEARISH BETS ON STERLING, BUT
LONGER TERM, YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT HUGE IMPLICATIONS FOR
BRITISH TRADE AND BRITISH
HEADQUARTERED COMPANIES.
WHAT WOULD BE THE REGULATIONS
FOR THEM?
A MORGAN STANLEY ANALYST SAID
TODAY OF COARSE THEY WOULD MOVE
THEIR HEADQUARTERS TO DUBLIN OR
FRANKFURT.
GUEST: IF YOUR ORGANIZATION
EMPLOYS AN IRISH PERSON, THAT'S
ONE THING THEY HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT.
MARK: HOW EMOTIONAL A VOTE HAS
IT BEEN NOT JUST TODAY BUT IN
THE RUN-UP COMPARED UP TO OTHER
BRITISH ELECTIONS?
GUEST: IT WAS GETTING EMOTIONAL
UNTIL JO COX WAS MURDERED.
BUT THEN IT CAME DOWN AGAIN.
FOR SOME PEOPLE, BRITAIN LEAVING
THE EUROPEAN UNION IS ONE OF THE
RATE CAUSES OF THEIR LIVES.
MAYBE THEY ARE FED UP WITH THE
REGULATION AND WANT TO TAKE BACK
THEIR SOVEREIGNTY.
OTHER PEOPLE FOR LESS HONORABLE
REASONS, THEY DON'T LIKE
IMMIGRANTS OR WHATEVER.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
CONSERVATIVE PARTY THOUGHT THIS
WAS THE BIG SINGLE THING WRITTEN
HAS DONE WRONG IN THE PAST 20 OR
30 YEARS, SO IT IS A SINGLE
ISSUE PASSION.
IT'S LIKE HAVING A REFERENDUM ON
ABORTION IN AMERICA.
FOR SOME PEOPLE, IT MATTERS IN
HONESTLY.
MARK: HOW HAS THAT MANIFESTED ON
TELEVISION AND IN DISCUSSION?
GUEST: THE PASSION AND FURY ROWS
AND ROWS, AS I WAS SAYING THE
OTHER DAY, IT ROSE AND ROSE AND
THEN WE HAVE THE MURDER OF JO
COX AND IT CHANGED THE RHETORIC.
DAVID CAMERON, HIS FUTURE
DEPENDS WHOLLY ON THIS.
VONNIE: YOU ALSO SOUGHT IN THE
SENSE OF WHO CAMPAIGNED WITH
WHOM.
YOU HAVE DAVID CAMERON AND
JEREMY CORBYN.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE DONALD TRUMP
AND HILLARY CLINTON TO PITCH ON
ONE ISSUE.
YOU WOULD NEVER SEE THAT IN THE
COURSE OF A NORMAL ELECTION
CYCLE.
GUEST: THEY MADE VERY ODD
BEDFELLOWS.
JOHN: THE PASSIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN STIRRED UP IN THIS ARE NOT
UNIQUE TO BRITAIN.
THEY ARE ALL ACROSS EUROPE AND
LOVE WESTERN DEMOCRACIES WITH A
FEAR OF IMMIGRATION,
PROTECTIONISM, ISOLATIONISM.
DO YOU THINK IF THE REMAIN VOTE
WINS THAT THOSE WILL SUBSIDE?
THEY HAVE BEEN ON THE RISE.
WITH THAT PUT A CAP ON THOSE
THINGS OR WOULD IT STILL BE A
BUBBLE IN A DANGEROUS WAY?
GUEST: UNLESS REMAIN WINS BY A
ENOUGH MARGIN, THEN CAMERON CAN
SAY WE HAVE SOLD THIS AND PUT IT
TO BED.
IF IT IS A NARROW MARGIN, PEOPLE
WILL SAY IT WAS DUE TO A
HORRIBLE MURDER, OTHERWISE WE
MIGHT HAVE -- WE MIGHT HAVE RUN.
A SOMEWHAT FRUMPY AND FURY ABOUT
IMMIGRATION -- THOSE ISSUES ARE
NOT GOING AWAY.
THERE ARE LESSONS WERE THE
AMERICANS.
ON THE REMAIN SIDE, PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT A TERRORIST
INCIDENT.
THE MURDER SEEMS TO HAVE
SWITCHED PEOPLE THE OTHER WAY.
PEOPLE CAN GET VERY ANGRY ABOUT
THESE THINGS BUT WHEN THEY ARE
CONFRONTED IN THAT LAST MOMENT,
THEY SEEM, IF THESE EXIT POLLS
ARE EVEN A LITTLE BIT CORRECT,
PEOPLE SEEM TO THINK I DON'T
WANT TO TRY THE UNKNOWN AND
THAT'S SOMETHING IF I WAS DONALD
TRUMP, I WOULD LOOK AT.
VONNIE: ALSO THE IDEA THAT YOU
HAVE MANY YEARS OF UNCERTAINTY
AND WOULD NOT IMMEDIATELY HAVE
AN EXIT FOR YOU HAVE TO INVOKE
ARTICLE 50 OF THE LISBON TREATY.
AND THEN OTHER EU LEADERS ARE
DECIDING HER FATE BECAUSE IT'S
TWO YEARS OF NEGOTIATIONS AND
YOU ARE NOT IN THE ROOM WITH
THOSE LEADERS.
JOHN: IF LEAVE TURNS OUT TO WIN,
WHAT HAPPENS TOMORROW MORNING?
VONNIE: NEXT WEEK, EU LEADERS
MEET AND DAVID CAMERON PROBABLY
HAS A HASTY MEETING WITH HIS
CABINET MEMBERS AND DECIDES WHAT
TO DO.
HE IS PROBABLY OUT OF A JOB AT
THAT POINT.
GUEST: AND THE MARKETS WOULD BE
IN TURMOIL AT THAT POINT.
THAT'S WHERE IT STARTS AFFECTING
THE WORLD ECONOMY IN THOSE
THINGS BECAUSE IN THE
BACKGROUND, THE PAST FEW DAYS,
MARKETS HAVE BEGUN TO RECOVER
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE BEGUN TO
BREATHE A RECITE -- BREATHE A
SIGH OF RELIEF.
I BELIEVE IT IS SOMEWHAT CLOSE
TO A LEHMAN MOMENT OR ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT COULD UPSET A
LOT OF OTHER THINGS.
VONNIE: BUT BRITAIN WOULD STILL
BE A MEMBER OF THE EU INTO A
VOTE WAS TAKEN TO WITHDRAW.
GUEST: YOU WOULD SIT THERE AND
THINK IT IS GOING TO COLLAPSE IN
VALUE.
VONNIE: AND CENTRAL BANKERS HAVE
THEIR ALARMS SET VERY EARLY.
THEY HAVE ALL SAID THEY WOULD BE
THERE IN CASE OF A LIQUIDITY
MOMENT.
JOHN: VONNIE QUINN -- I'M
PRAYING FOR ALL OF YOUR VAST
REAL ESTATE HOLDINGS BOTH IN
LONDON AND IN THE COUNTRYSIDE.
STAY WITH US FOR THE LATEST ON
THIS HUGE STORY.
UP NEXT, TED CRUZ'S CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AND MICHAEL CAPUTO.
YOU CAN LISTEN TO US ON THE
RADIO RADIO IN WASHINGTON, D C.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: OUR NEXT GUEST TONIGHT IS
THE FORMER CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR
TED CRUZ AND HERE IN THE STUDIO,
MICHAEL CAPUTO, FORMER ADVISER
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WHO
RESIGNED EARLIER THIS WEEK AFTER
HE POSTED CELEBRATING THE FIRING
OF TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
THEY ARE BOTH FANS OF THE
PROGRAM.
DESPITE LEAVING THE CAMPAIGN,
MICHAEL, WHAT IS YOUR PUBLIC
POSTURE ON WHETHER YOU ARE A
TRUMP MAN?
GUEST: HIS SPEECH YESTERDAY TOOK
A BIG STEP FORWARD AND TODAY,
HIS POSITION ON JUDGES MAKES A
STARK REACTION OF WHAT THIS
CAMPAIGN WILL BE ABOUT AND WHAT
THE RESULTS MEAN FOR AMERICA.
BUT I'M WAITING TO SEE HOW
DONALD CONDUCTS THE CAMPAIGN AND
EARNS OUR VOTE.
MARK: YOU HEAR THAT FROM A
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN -- HOW
DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE CHALLENGE
FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
GUEST: I THINK THERE ARE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE WAITING FOR A
FEW MORE POINTS ON THIS LINE TO
CALL IT A TREND.
I'M CONFIDENT WE WILL SEE A
WHOLE DIFFERENT KIND OF CAMPAIGN
AFTER THE DECISION IS MADE ON
MONDAY.
I BELIEVE HE IS PUTTING UP THE
STRUCTURE HE HAS ALWAYS WANTED
TO PUT UP AND I THINK DONALD
TRUMP WILL GET THE CAMPAIGN HE
DESERVES AND SKEPTICS WILL SERVE
TO SEE THIS IS SOMETHING HE CAN
GET BEHIND.
JOHN: THE MAY FUNDRAISING
NUMBERS WERE VERY BAD.
ON THE GROUND AM A VERY WEAK.
MR. TRUMP SAYS HE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT EIGHT OR DATA ANALYTICS.
HOW MUCH OF THAT DO YOU
CORRELATE?
GUEST: IT'S ABOUT WHERE THIS
CAMPAIGN IS GOING FORWARD.
WE SAW THE NEWS YESTERDAY THAT
MR. TRUMP BROKE MOST RECORDS FOR
ONLINE FUNDRAISING.
YOU GUYS DID GOOD ONLINE AS WELL
BUT IT IS TREMENDOUS -- $3
MILLION IN 24 HOURS AND HE HAS
NEVER USED THAT LIST FOR.
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE BE READY FOR
A $20 MILLION AMOUNT ONLINE
FUNDRAISING TURN FROM HIS LIST
AND I THINK THE MECHANICS OF
FUNDRAISING, EVENTS, THE
INTERNAL PROCESSES THAT NEED TO
BE PUT IN PLACE ARE NOW IN PLACE
AND THE DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE
ON MONDAY ARE MOVING SOME OF THE
WOOD THAT WAS IN THE WAY WE WILL
SEE MORE SUCCESS IN FUNDRAISING.
ON THE GROUND, YOU'LL SEE A LOT
MORE HIRING.
THERE ARE PEOPLE BEING
CONSIDERED WITH THE DECISIONS ON
MONDAY IN THOSE HIRES WILL
HAPPEN.
A LOT OF THINGS YOU EXPECT FROM
A TRADITIONAL CAMPAIGN WILL BE
PUT UP FROM HERE FORWARD.
JOHN: YOU ARE A BIG FAN OF DATA,
TARGETING, GROUND GAME AND
LEADING-EDGE CAMPAIGN
TECHNIQUES.
I KNOW YOU ARE ON THE OUTSIDE,
BUT AS AN OBSERVER OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THE STATEMENTS IT
HAS MADE AND WHAT WE KNOW FROM
THE REPORTING AND MR. TRUMP'S
OWN ASSERTIONS, HOW WORRIED ARE
YOU ABOUT THE STATE OF THE
CAMPAIGN?
IS THAT A CAMPAIGN IN A STATE OF
CRISIS, AS IT LOOKS TO SOME
REPUBLICAN OPERATIVES?
GUEST: I WOULD BE REMISS THAT
WITHOUT DATA, THEY WOULD KICK MY
BUT ANYWAY AND THAT IS ON TOP
WAS RAISING $93 MILLION, WHICH
WAS A RECORD FOR REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES GETTING 8 MILLION
VOTES AND MR. TRUMP HAS A WAY TO
CONTROL THE NEWS CYCLE.
THEY HAVE TO GET GOING RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT THIS BOILS DOWN TO IS DATA
AND ANALYTICS AND GROUND EQUATES
TO ABOUT A POINT IN A HALF,
DEPENDING ON HOW THE DEMOCRATS
ARE DOING IT AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE CLEARLY DOING WELL BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ONE SO MANY CAMPAIGNS
WITHIN THE MARGIN OF ERROR.
THAT MEANS THE GROUND GAME MADE
A DIFFERENCE.
THE RNC HAS DONE A GOOD JOB.
IT IS A GENERIC MODEL, SO THEY
NEED TO MAKE IT TRUMP SPECIFIC.
IN THE LAST YOU DAYS, FOR WHAT
HAS BEEN SIX AND A HALF WEEKS OF
TOUGH STUFF FOR THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, HE IS STILL IN THE
MARGIN OF AIR OR UP IN THE
PLACES THAT HE NEEDS TO BE AN
DOING BETTER IN PLACES THAN YOU
ANTICIPATE IN PLACES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA.
THERE IS TIME TO CATCH UP, BUT
THEY HAVE TO CATCH UP.
MARK: SMARTEST PICK FOR VICE
PRESIDENT?
GUEST: TOM COTTON.
GUEST: ANYBODY BESIDES NEWT
GINGRICH.
MARK: THE SMARTEST THING THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN IS DOING IS?
GUEST: KEEPING THE PRESSURE ON
DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THEY WILL START GETTING
SOME PUSHBACK.
GUEST: I THINK THEY'RE ON GROUND
MECHANICS IS WHAT YOU SEE RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THEY ARE DOING THE
BEST.
MARK: KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT THE
CONVENTION?
GUEST: THAT'S HARD TO SAY.
I WISH I COULD SEE JACK KEMP UP
THERE SPEAKING.
MARK: GO WITH SOMEBODY ALIVE, IF
YOU WOULD.
GUEST: IF YOU WANT TO RALLY THE
CONSERVATIVES AND PUT A STAMP ON
THE PARTY AND TAKE US INTO A
GENERAL ELECTION, I THINK TED
CRUZ YOU HAVE A BIGGER ROLE IN
THE CONVENTION.
MARK: STANDBY.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK LET THE
CLEVELAND CONVENTION AND WHETHER
THERE WILL BE MORE EXCITEMENT
THERE THAN USUAL RIGHT AFTER
THIS.
♪
JOHN: WE ARE BACK WITH THE
CAPTAIN OF TED CRUZ'S CAMPAIGN
AND A FORMER ADVISOR TO DONALD
TRUMP.
YOU WERE IN YOUR ADVISOR PASSY
WORKING HARD OUT OF CLEVELAND
OHIO, GETTING READY FOR THE
CONVENTION.
GIVE A SENSE OF HOW APPEARED TO
CAMPAIGN WAS FOR THE POSSIBILITY
OF A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE TO
MR. TRUMP'S NOMINATION.
GUEST: THE TRUMP OFFICE AT THE
CONVENTION HAS BEEN PREPARING
FOR A LOAD OF CHICANERY.
THEY HAVE AN EXPECTING
SOMETHING.
WE ARE HOPEFUL IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT THE COMMUNICATIONS
TEAM WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE ARE
ARMY VETERANS AND COMBAT
VETERANS, SOLID COMMUNICATORS
WITH A LOT OF EXPERIENCE, MORE
VETERANS THAN ON ANY OTHER TEAM
IN POLITICS AND I WILL TELL YOU,
OUR FLOOR OPERATIONS TEAM IS
GOING TO BE STELLAR.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE ANYONE
TO COMPARE IT TO IN RECENT
TIMES.
I THINK IF SOMEONE WANTS TO PLAY
GAME IN CLEVELAND, THEY BETTER
BRING IT ON.
JOHN: YOU WERE PREPARING TO BE
ONE OF THOSE CHICANERY END-USERS
WHEN WE THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE A
CONTESTED CONVENTION.
WHAT IS YOUR SENSE OF THE DEGREE
OF ENERGY, ORGANIZATION,
MOTIVATION OF THOSE WHO WOULD
TELL LIKE TO TRY TO DUMP TRUMP?
GUEST: I THINK THERE IS SOME
THERE.
I THINK THE LAST SIX WEEKS HAS
PUT THIS IN MOTION AND GIVEN IT
ENERGY.
DEPENDING ON HOW THE CAMPAIGN
PROGRESSES IN THE NEXT THREE
WEEKS WILL BE DETERMINATIVE OF
HOW MUCH ENERGY THERE IS.
ESSENTIALLY, REPUBLICANS WANT TO
WIN AND WHEN WE SEE WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE LAST X WEEKS TO
WE ARE CONCERNED.
WHEN I TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT
THIS, IT'S PROBABLY 50% MORE
ORGANIZED, DISCIPLINED, BETTER
FUNDED THEN YOU WOULD HOPE AND
PROBABLY 25% LESS THAN YOU WOULD
FEAR.
THERE ARE SOME TALENTED PEOPLE
INVOLVED AND THEY HAVE SOME
MONEY.
OUR POSTURE IS DONALD TRUMP WON
THE NOMINATION AND IS GOING TO
BE THE NOMINEE.
IF OTHER THINGS HAPPEN, THAT IS
OUT OF OUR CONTROL.
WE ARE NOT IN TALKS WITH THE
EFFORT, BUT IN MY ESTIMATION,
TRUMP COULD PUT THAT AWAY IN THE
NEXT THREE WEEKS.
MARK: WHY ISN'T SENATOR CRUZ ON
THE TRUMP TRAIN?
GUEST: IT WAS A VERY AGGRESSIVE
CAMPAIGN FOR A YEAR --
MARK: THERE WAS AN AGGRESSIVE
CAMPAIGN AGAINST CARSON.
IS IT PERSONAL?
YOU SAY REPUBLICANS WANT TO WIN
AND DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
THE NOMINEE.
WHAT IS SENATOR CRUZ WAITING
FOR?
GUEST: THERE ARE 130 EIGHT DAYS
LEFT, SO A LOT OF WATER CAN PASS
UNDER THE BRIDGE.
WE WERE CAMPAIGNING ABOUT THE
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY AND
CONSERVATIVE VALUES AND WE HAD A
STRONG CONVERSATION FOR OVER A
YEAR.
I THINK IT'S OK TO TAKE STOCK
AND SEE HOW THE CAMPAIGN WORKS
OUT AND HAVE THE TRUNK CAMPAIGN
WIN OVER OUR VOTE AND PUT
EVERYONE IN THE SAME WAGON FULL
OF -- SAME WAGON.
MARK: DONALD TRUMP SAID JEB BUSH
AND TED CRUZ WERE BEHIND SOME OF
THESE THINGS.
GUEST: TED CRUZ WAS THE ONLY ONE
WHO REQUESTED A DIFFERENT ROOM.
MARK: WHO DENIED IT?
GUEST: THE CONVENTION DID.
JOHN: WOULD YOU SAY THAT YOU
PERSONALLY DENIED IT?
GUEST: I WOULD TWEETED, IF I
DID.
THIS THING PETERS OUT WITH A
STRONG AND POSITIVE CAMPAIGN
THAT GETS DOWN TO THE IMPORTANT,
DISTILLED MESSAGES THAT DONALD
TRUMP KNOWS VERY WELL.
YOU ARE EITHER FOR CHANGE OR YOU
ARE FOR MORE OF THE SAME EIGHT
MORE YEARS OF BARACK OBAMA.
I THINK YOU SAW SOME OF THAT IN
THE SPEECH YESTERDAY.
THE CONFERENCE CALLS TRYING TO
GIN UP THE DUMPED TRUNK MOVEMENT
AND TALKING ABOUT 400 PEOPLE
BEING ON THE CALL.
280 STAYED ON FOR LESS THAN A
MINUTE.
GUEST: THAT MUST BE THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT YOU GOT WHERE
WE REQUESTED A MEETING ROOM.
I WOULD KNOW IF WE DID AND WE
DID NOT.
JOHN: WHO MADE THE REQUEST?
GUEST: IT CAME FROM THE CRUISE
EFFORT.
GUEST: IT WAS THE SAME DAY THAT
HIS FATHER SHOT JFK.
MARK: WHO'S THE SECOND MOST
LIKELY REPUBLICAN NOMINEE?
GUEST: I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ONE.
I THINK TRUMP IS OUR NOMINEE AND
I THINK HE HAS NEVER TWO TO PUT
ALL OF US IN THE SAME WAGON.
MARK: YOU SAID THE DUMP TRUMP
MOVEMENT WAS 50% MORE ORGANIZED
THAN YOU WOULD HAVE HOPED.
SO IT IS A REAL THING.
I THINK EVERYONE ASSUMES THE
REASON HE HAS NOT ENDORSED
DONALD TRUMP AS HE WANTS TO KEEP
HIS OPTIONS OPEN AND IF THAT
MOVEMENT DOES GEL ARE YOU SAYING
THERE IS NO TRUTH TO THAT ALL?
GUEST: WE SUITED UP, GOT IN THE
RACE AND ONE A DOZEN STATES AND
PUT IT ON THE FIELD EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
WE ARE NOT IN THE JUNGLE WITH A
KNIFE AND ARTISTES WAITING FOR
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY TO STRIKE.
HE'S JUST TAKING SOME TIME AND
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO ARE DOING
THE SAME THING.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT THE
CONSERVATIVE VALUES THAT HE
CAMPAIGNED ON ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO HIM.
I'M SURE THE TWO OF THEM WILL
GET IN A ROOM AND DISCUSS THEIR
DIFFERENCES AND WE WILL SEE WHAT
COMES OUT OF THAT MEETING.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED BUT I THINK
IT WILL TAKE THAT TO HAVE ANY
KIND OF CONVERSATION MOVING
FORWARD.
JOHN: THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING
ON AND WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: NOTHING MORE FUN THAN
WAITING FOR ELECTION RESULTS AND
THEY WILL BE COMING IN SOON AND
INTO THE NIGHT.
YOU CAN ALWAYS GO TO BLOOMBERG
POLITICS.COM AND READ THE
LATEST.
THERE IS A BUSINESS WEEK
MAGAZINE EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH BARACK OBAMA.
THE PRESIDENT HAD LOTS TO SAY
ABOUT LOTS OF STUFF, SOME ABOUT
HIS FAMILY, SOME ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
CHECK IT OUT.
JOHN: WATCH BLOOMBERG TV
COVERAGE OF THE BREXIT RESULTS.
IT IS IMPORTANT AND WE ARE GOING
TO COVER IT BETTER THAN ANYONE.
UNTIL TOMORROW, SAYONARA.
♪
BETTY: YOU ARE WATCHING A
SPECIAL COVERAGE OF BRITAIN
DECIDES -- HISTORY UNFOLDING
BEFORE OUR VERY EYES.
WE WAIT FOR THE RESULTS OF ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT VOTES IN
BRITISH AND EUROPEAN HISTORY.
WILL BRITAIN STAY IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION OR BREAK THE